oh hi welcome to game life you might
think that the big video game news this
week is the launch of nintendo's new
console the Wii U but millions of gamers
would actually disagree with you because
Activision has got a little something up
its sleeve as well that's right it's
call of duty black ops 2 when everyone
calls in sick to work on Tuesday this is
why they'll be crowding the server's
putting bullets into each other's heads
and furiously leveling up their
characters
this year's installment of call of duty
will let players instantly livestream
their matches including audio and webcam
video through YouTube black ops 2 will
be available November 13 for xbox 360
playstation 3 and pc with a wii u
version coming on the 18th if you're
more into o medieval weapons made out of
colorful plastic you might be picking up
lego lord of the rings on the same day
thrilled to the adventures of Frodo and
the Fellowship finally told as they were
always meant to be by tiny plastic Lego
men lego lord of the rings is available
tuesday for pretty much every game
system except the wii u and speaking of
which hey look it's the wii u nintendo's
new console which comes with this crazy
touchscreen-based controller is going to
be on store shelves sunday november 18
23 games are going to be available on
day 1 and while we can't show you all of
them here's a few pics that we think you
should consider buying for your new toy
nintendo land is that we use wii sports
a collection of minigames that show off
the various ways you can play with two
screens everything is themed after a
popular nintendo franchise from zelda 2
Pikmin 2 f 0 it's packed in with the
three hundred and fifty dollar deluxe
wii u package but if you get the
bare-bones $300 set you'll have to buy a
nintendo land separately new super mario
brothers you should be self-explanatory
at this point up to five players can
enjoy it together for people can run and
jump through the levels while the fifth
holds the tablet and adds helpful blocks
to the screen by tapping or a solo
player can enjoy it all by himself
without even having to use the TV
Epic Mickey to the power of two comes
out for Wii U the old wii playstation 3
xbox 360 and pc all on the same day this
time around two players can play
together playing as Mickey Mouse and his
friend me hace all the Lucky Rabbit not
only that the characters talk this time
around they also sing Ubisoft loves to
go big on new consoles and it's going so
big on the Wii U that it will have more
launch games than even Nintendo does the
biggest one is rabbids land another fun
collection of minigames starring those
crazy crazy bunnies on the total
opposite end of the spectrum is zombie
you a very scary horror game hitting you
against an army of undead you can search
for supplies on the controller screen
but remember to glance up at the TV to
make sure you're not about to become
food we will have many more impressions
of new Wii U games in the days to come
so keep an eye on wired.com / game life
for our continuing coverage and we'll
see you next week
you